chers compatriotes face à l'effroi qui
nous saisit face à l'horreur des
attaques terroristes survenues
l'heure est à la solidarité de tous les
français à l'endroit des victimes et de
leurs proches nous pensons à celles qui
y ont succombé et leurs familles
nous pensons à celles qui luttent pour
la vie à toutes celles qui sont
hospitalisés à celles qui sont blessés
dans leur chair nous pensons aussi à
tous ceux qui ont été les témoins
directs de ces atrocités qui ont assisté
à des scènes abominable parce qu'à côté
des blessures physiques qu'il y a
également les traumatismes
psychologiques qui sont dans de telles
circonstances
si l'eau nous pensons forces de sécurité
et aux secours dont le courage et la
détermination ont une nouvelle fois
était admirable qu'elle sache ses forces
de sécurité de secours qu'elles ont le
soutien de tous les français
mes chers compatriotes les terroristes
ont engagé la guerre à la france notre
pays ne doit pas céder notre pays ne
doit pas reculer partout en france nous
reviennent des messages qui montre à
quel point notre peuple est déterminé à
vaincre la barbarie djihadistes la
guerre que nous devons livrer doit être
totale notre devoir est de prendre en
compte l'extrême gravité de la situation
et d'en tirer toutes les conséquences en
terme d'action
rien ne peut être comme avant le
terrorisme a fait trop de victimes
nous devons comprendre les raisons qui
expliquent que de telles attaques soit
possible et en tirer immédiatement les
conséquences
notre politique extérieure doit intégrer
le fait que nous sommes en guerre notre
politique de sécurité intérieure
également nous avons besoin d'inflexion
majeure pour que la sécurité des
français soit pleinement tu assures et
au delà du nécessaire état d'urgence et
des contrôles aux frontières
nous soutiendrons toutes les décisions
qu'ils iront dans le sens d'un
renforcement drastique des mesures de
sécurité qui permettront de protéger la
vie de nos compatriotes notre nation
doit être soudé la france est grande
la france est grande de ses valeurs de
son identité et de son peuple
notre histoire est chargé des preuves
nous avons toujours su les surmonter
nous surmonterons celle ci avec sang
froid avec détermination et avec force
mes chers compatriotes vive la
république et vive la france